all right perfect so awesome to have you
here thank you thank you
we're going to talk about what every
nodejs developer needs to know about
elixir today there's me on Twitter I
respond on Twitter so hit me there I
love carrying this conversation on out
of here and if you have any questions
always follow up with me there there's
no expiration date on that so I want to
start off this illustration appeared in
The Guardian shortly after December 25th
1914 and this is an illustration of the
Christmas truce where the German and
British soldiers that were a trench
warfare they would this excuse of coming
out and burying their dead they got
together and they were civil to each
other in the middle of this horror that
was going on they stepped out and they
acknowledge each other's humanity and in
technology tech we often break off into
camps and we don't do that so well a lot
of times we don't reach out and so for
the node folks here I really appreciate
you all come into a functional
programming talk and for the functional
program people I'm really glad you're
here to to think about this node side of
things and so at the point that we make
problems visible then you can do
something about it you can improve the
situation but until you make them
visible it doesn't really happen and so
thanks so this idea of civility we might
hate a technology there might be
problems with the technology we might
know that the technology is dangerous
but you have to understand how people
got there and have empathy for them and
and on both directions so my path
had the sort of long road you can tell
by my gray hair that I began writing
software professionally back in 1994 and
so I was writing C and V B so the old VB
not V V net but kicking it old school
and then Pascal at vbscript jscript
javascript and then c-sharp on and
through that path you know I ran into
lots and lots of problems I created lots
of problems you know like like we all do
but I probably created more than my
share of problems and through that I I
might not have been the best developer
but I was awfully good at seeing the my
mistakes and trying to learn from them
and seeing what the pitfalls were that
led me there and through that I worked
to try to help other people avoid
pitfalls and that empathy that I tried
to use in in this land of imperative
code in O code during the 90s and the
odds interestingly it had this
reputation for being able to see these
problems and help and that led me then
to Norway 2007 so I was here was brought
over for a large architectural risk
assessment project so here in Oslo there
was a company that had a huge codebase I
had 20 million lines of managed C++ and
C sharp code that these 12 architects
and we worked on this risk assessment of
how is the software going to destroy the
company project over the 6-week period
and through that all of the problems
that I imagined would be in the codebase
you know those were there its you could
almost get Robert Martin's book and just
hand that book over before you even went
in and looked at the code because those
problems are common across all
imperative and OO systems those code
smells are there and so that was
expected that side of it amazing team
but do you expect the problems one thing
I didn't expect though is there was a
system in that in that shop that had
been up and running for four years
without a millisecond of downtime say
all the other sec all the other
applications they were crashing maybe
multiple times a day it was embarrassing
was causing trouble you've had
dependencies within the code that made
it hard to upgrade you had the mingling
of state data and behavior like we're
told to do by Martin Fowler we had that
all through the code and that caused all
these defects in the software that made
death it was really hard to solve
problems and we had to
event storms because it was you had
concurrency involved in this concurrency
is hard to do if you have mutable state
problem problem problem but this system
for years without a millisecond of
downtime that was unusual and so I asked
more and more about it and I actually
learned is even more remarkable there
had been two years previously there had
been a major code upgrade this compiled
language they compiled and they had
pushed new updates to this running
cluster without a millisecond of
downtime then so I was like what is the
spooky magic and so I learned for the
first time the word Erlang I never heard
of it I was off imperative oo guy you
know and and I was happy they're sort of
happy I knew I had problems and I knew
there were problems but but I was
comfortable there and so I dug in and I
started learning more about Erlang and
my code changed and I have built systems
that people tell stories about now that
you know they've seen these good things
and I couldn't have done that before
before I run into the Erlang VM and so
it changed my life and so I'd like to
come back to Norway and you know share
you know return the favor so I'm very
thankful for this city and for for what
it's done for me and all the defects
it's kept me out of so here we have the
hero's journey this is sort of the arc
that all novels and movies and
everything follow this arc of the hero's
journey and so that was the beginning of
my hero's journey and hopefully you know
you this will be the beginning of your
hero's journey as you go through and you
pick up these some of this knowledge
will go through this ordinary world and
will progress so for the node folks here
I imagine you came to node for some of
these reasons it's really a welcoming
community you can come in without
knowing much about programming at all
and you know you're welcome to N and
that's awesome and it's easy to get
started in node and there's no doubt
about that it's easy to get started and
you can you can be working in angular uh
Durandal aurélia one of these frameworks
and if you need to have a back-end you
need to stand that back up in quickly
well you can do that and node it's it's
very easy to to kick that up everyone
sort of knows JavaScript no one really
knows JavaScript everyone sort of knows
it then
people also come because they've been
hurt in other stacks there's problems of
the tools being too heavy or not being
able to have enough control over things
just various problems and there is a
concurrency story on node it's different
than I think a lot of people think it is
but there is a story there and then
people know that concurrency is
important so if that brings people and
then there's good support in Visual
Studio and and on Azure I think of this
this sort of progression in node and I
have lots of friends that went through
node I started working in node when it
was brand China new because I was
interested in the story of it I pretty
quickly then dropped it because I had
already learned Earling at that point
and I saw it's like this isn't really
filling the bargain that I thought it
should be and so but this is this
progression we start off with folks that
are junior and they're full of optimism
you know they they haven't even heard
the horror stories yet they haven't
heard any of the bad it's just this
welcoming community they come in and
they're they're excited about this and
that is that is a beautiful thing to
have and at some point you move on and
you then have your sort of engineers and
they have heard the problems maybe
they've seen a few problems but the
thing is is they can they can say I'll
be a craftsman I see these problems
they're documented I'll know how to
actually be diligent and not run into
these problems myself and that's that
peer this is the second stage of no
development and then you move on to the
seniors and the leads and I have friends
that are in the spot right now they
bought into this they brought their
companies along and they've heard the
problems they've seen the problems and
now they're like oh my god what have I
done
you know they got themselves in a trap
because they used it for everything they
used it for things far far outside of
its sweet spot and they're in a terrible
place and they're having trouble
shipping code that's rough that's a
rough spot to be in and those folks I'm
excited about where they're at I'm
excited about all of these these groups
coming in because it's a great feeder
into elixir I believe but the folks that
are senior they're looking for escape
pods and a lot of them are joining up at
the elixir user groups around the
country
so around the world so you'll have this
mix of Ruby people and you'll have this
mix of node people and then if you
scattered FP people showing up the
elixir meetups and so I'm really tickled
about this this linkage in this
connection when on node when people talk
about node they often use the word
scalable and it's sort of a problem I
believe to use the word scalable in the
context of node well scalable is a rough
word it's a sort of a buzzword marketing
word it's a word that managers like to
use even though they don't know what
what it means and it I feel like you
could say oK you've got a fast car
describing a cars a fast car you've got
a car that goes and flies through the
guardrails and falls down the bluff at
terminal velocity and you could say that
that's a fast car but you're missing an
important part of the story by calling
that a fast car you know there's other
things going on and so when you called
nodes scalable there's an issue in that
that it can handle the 20,000
connections that come in it can handle
the 20,000 users as long as you
immediately pass that off for something
else to do the work
because if you do the work you then have
got this issue of where you're blocking
you're blocking your other 19 thousand
999 users so the issue then is like okay
we hand off the work or who's going to
do the work then and what do we write
that in and there are all sorts of
solutions every time you run into a
problem there are there's a lot of
ingenuity in the node community and they
have solutions you'll have things like
queue and you have these ways of just
passing things off these libraries have
been written but it's always hard manual
work and a lot of learning and
discipline involved a lot of folks
you'll see a lot of blog posts that will
say node is not a silver bullet and I
think you could say that about most
technologies you know it's not the thing
that solves everything but there's
another way of actually looking at the
problem of silver bullet and in this
sense I think maybe node is a silver
bullet in that a silver bullet has a
really narrow use case and there's a
sweet spot for a silver bullet and that
is to kill werewolves and day to day
there aren't nearly as many werewolves
running around Hollywood would make you
think
and so the sweet spots that you would
fit there aren't as many solutions where
it does map up closely and so more more
of an uglier view of this might be it's
maybe not the Silver Bullet maybe it's
more like the full moon that brings out
sort of some crazy in the environment
and I'm kind of off of this part of the
talk but I've seen so many of my friends
hurt by this and I believe that this is
the most dangerous technology in the
world and and so and I hope that you
take this in the spirit that I'm
offering it that that I'm truly trying
to help and I'm trying to keep problems
from happening
so let's now move on to elixir and how
it came to be so we've got this history
of a character named Jose a villain who
is here at the conference this week to
speak and so he was a core member of the
Ruby on Rails team and he he was trying
to solve problems on Ruby although you
know he's a good developer he's focused
on these issues it's hard to solve
problems on on Ruby like people would
ask for scale they would ask for
concurrency that ask for performance and
that's a hard thing to deliver on the on
the on Ruby and so he was battling that
battle and he was then reading seven
languages in seven weeks out of
curiosity who else heard this book
awesome awesome
yeah and so he got to the chapter on
Erlang and he's like whoa he was kind of
like everyone does when they first hear
about what this thing does and like
that's weird
I haven't I heard of this thing and so
he was reading about Erlang and he saw
that it fit these problems of
fault-tolerance concurrency distribution
this scale thing that he had been asked
to solve and so he started looking into
Erlang then it's like first like
everyone does when they first bumped
into Erling they think okay can I steal
part some Erlang and bring it over into
my stack and their reasons you can't do
that that we'll talk about briefly it's
really hard it's a part hard problem and
so he really he's a smart guy he
realized it pretty quickly you can't do
this it's not going to happen so he
thought maybe I'll become an Erlang
developer okay Ruby is known for one
thing and that's it's it's about
developer joy right it's a path it's a
happy place
via developer they hug each other you
know it's like a good good spot it's not
necessarily known for you know those
other things we're talking about but it
is about developer joy now you could say
the reverse about Erlang so it is good
about solving these hard engineering
problems you've got these crusty
engineers that created the language two
of them are here this week so we have
Joe Armstrong Robert Verdun crusty
serious engineer guys and and so they
weren't focused on the problem of dev
joy at Ericsson and Sweden in Stockholm
they weren't they weren't focused on
that problem and so josei decided I'm
gonna take I've got another approach
instead of trying to rip off Erlang what
I'm going to do is I'm going to write a
new language that targets the the
targets the Erlang VM and that's the
path he went down it's like I'm going to
build developer joy good modern tooling
all this on top of this VM that has this
amazing track record and we're going to
talk now about the sweet spots so elixir
it's also approachable and it's
productive not just in the short term
but in the long term so it's
approachable productive and you have
modern tooling so first about
approachable we can look at you go to
elixir laying org and it's a useful
website you know it's not just a thing
because you got to have a website it's
really useful of learning the language
and so if you jump in there and you go
to the getting started guide down on the
right here you see one through 21 and
you actually have a really good handle
of the language just by following those
pages you can start here instead of
getting a book and you'll do fine then
as you're going through that you can
also go to this other link here and find
all the meetups around the world and
you'll see a bunch of Ruby people and a
bunch of node people and functional
programming people scattered in this is
the pattern I've seen city by city you
can go to github see the code see the
language and contribute and you'll have
feedback from Josie right on the side so
you have this you get a pull request and
he's sending hearts all over the place
and so this is a nice thing to see this
Ruby love showing up inside of this list
language he's a great guardian of the
language he's a great protector and he's
also very interested in bringing in
ideas from from all outside places
another part of the tool
story is hex you have hex PM is the
package management system it targets so
you can use this for your Erlang code
which you don't have because there
aren't any Earling developers in the
world there's like maybe 510 you know
there are a few of us and so there
aren't many but this lik sir side there
are a lot and and that's a growing thing
and so we go off and we see some of the
libraries out here you won't find
libraries that do like three lines of
code libraries these are libraries that
take on more serious things that people
need all the time but you won't have
your six lines of code on a package and
also if you go to something like ecto
and look at you'll see that the that the
level is pretty good here this is the
documentation off of a package that you
pull down from hex hex is fast all sorts
of good qualities about it
packages don't disappear on you on hex
it's this immutable store of packages
packages disappearing on you this of
course has been in the news this year
poor fella over here a sir god bless him
and so uh you know so he took a beating
and there's a lot of beading that went
on there's a lot of schadenfreude oh
there's a lot of there's a lot of
negative that happened here but I think
it's comment by Tracy harms is really
nice this catastrophe fault of a single
single solitary developers decisions and
if a complete stranger can push some
buttons and break your production
deployment you have something some
thinking to do especially if that was
around six lines of code that was really
about doing something the language
should have done anyway out of the box
okay modern tooling so we'll have this
sort of retro modern hipster bicycle
thing here and so like all modern
languages we have the terminal it's the
way you do your good work and so so we
return to the terminal here IEX the
interactive elixir shell when we say IEX
that brings up an Erlang node so it
brings up an instance of the Erlang
virtual machine and loads up all the
elixir goodies here
okay we go IEX and we are inside of IEX
and we can do something like H at noon
so help we're going to help on this
thing we at dot we tab and we get auto
completion of all of the functions
within the Anu module or within the Anu
now with doing the Anu module and so we
say I'm interested in what count one
does the count that takes one argument
I'm interested in what that one does so
we get this nice color we get examples
right in the examples and this is the
way you can go through all of the
libraries and elixir in and you have
this help right at your fingertips
mix is another tool IX is a tool mix as
a tool mix is ripped off from closure
community this tool called line again
there which you know you can see some of
the the commands we can do this you can
think of it build code run your test
scaffold new projects and it's pluggable
so additional things can come in so
let's say mix new fizzbuzz we're going
to scaffold out fizzbuzz and here we go
well you get a readme markdown file
which is nice and modern we get a get
ignore built in which has our ignores
that we would want to have an elixir
project that's nice and modern and we
are config and so when we have our
fizzbuzz module and then we have tests I
mean this is nice you know we come in
here and this is a nice place to be so
let's go into CDN to fizzbuzz let say
mix test look compiled and right out of
the box we get one passing test so they
already started off for us with a
template for us to have tests so let's
now go in and see
what that story looks like
okay so I have here our
scaffolded out code off of our fizzbuzz
this is just what is so this is our one
test that you know that would scaffold
out for us and that's what we had our
one now I have a fully implemented
fizzbuzz over here and we can see it's
down here we we play to a number and it
does a bunch of stuff that we don't have
to worry about yet because we're going
to see about the syntax in a minute the
thing I wanted to show here was the
experience of saying mix test okay said
we have three tests and one failure so
we saw one test a minute ago what's that
about and why do we have a failed test
let's go in here and see what this
failed test actually is so it says here
fizzbuzz play 10 to 16 and it expected a
fizzbuzz here but we had a fizz and
stead so let's go up here and see what
that's about
so what we have here is
this is not a regular comment this is a
doc test and so right in the middle of
our comments we've included examples of
usage to make it easy for people to come
in and right here this becomes part of
our test suite so we have fizzbuzz play
one two five that should get this and
that became a unit test fizzbuzz played
ten to sixteen should get this and that
became a unit test that actually failed
on us because we have a bug down here we
have a pattern match that's too greedy
and so what we need to do is move this
code up here do this and then we need to
move down here and we need to rerun our
tests oops i forgot to save dinner
yeah so so our test pass now that was
based off of that doc test so I think
that's pretty sweet
okay so another productive nice sweet
part of elixir is the Phoenix framework
so this is a web framework that was
built by the fellow who just walked in
here Joe's a valium created a language
and sunny Scroggins back there and Chris
McCord and there's a bunch of awesome
people chris was here last year gave a
talk it's on the on Vimeo and so Phoenix
is amazing but I'm not going to talk
about it because there's a lot of good
content about it by people here later
today but this is what a lot of people
want when they come to a web framework
so elixir is functional and so we've
probably heard a lot of buzz about
functional over the last few years and
so a simple way of looking about
functional is you have inputs that are
transformed by a function and you have
then outputs a goes to B inputs go to
outputs you don't have I'm going to come
in I'm going to set the table with all
my state I'm going to set fields
properties I'm going to have a class all
this stuff and I'm going to call then
functions that are going to mutate state
and then I'm going to lose track of what
I just did a minute ago and I'm going to
have all these bugs instead you can look
at the class what came in is the input
and know what should have happened
inside of the function in return this is
important and this is a good way of
getting out of a lot of those troubles
that I saw when I was my first trip to
Norway
mutability is another part of functional
programming and elixir takes this very
seriously it has to take this very
seriously because Erlang VM has a hard
set of rules that it enforces and this
is one of them so it's not a thing you
can turn off separation of data and
behavior so this is the thing we're
talking about earlier about classes with
their fields their properties the data
in their behavior mingle together which
limits the use that you'll be able to
handle and use that class in this is an
elixir you have modules that have
functions you don't have property seals
you so you call into a module and you
call a function within a module and it's
just the inputs that come in and then
the outputs that they go
so you spawn up a new process and you
say this process I need to call into
this function passing in this input I'm
going to take the output of that and
feed that into another function and you
just pipeline these things together and
that's the way you build programs and
side of a lick sir
so we've expressive dev Julie let's talk
a bit about the language now so language
language language
okay so we have IEX again and we're
going to look at some of the types here
so we have integer expected
Oh X - a that's kind of nice you know we
get our hex right there you know we
don't get barked at for having seven
float divided by three it just does the
thing you'd expect the thing you have
type called atoms that are sort of
there'd them there the thing themselves
they're only comparable to themselves
they're just a handle or a constant that
even if you have a whole cluster of
different machines this like that the
atom goat is equal to the atom goat on
the other server and it's not equal to
anything other than the atom goat
strings are real strings inside of
elixir you might have heard stories
horror stories about Erlang whereas like
oh it's bad at strings and it turns out
it was a problem with naming was the
problem with Erlang and strings the
thing they call the string is not what
people expected it to be and in elixir a
string is what you expect it to be you
know you get this utf-8
binary good thing and it behaves like if
you would expect it to actually behaves
a little bit better than you expect it
to and we'll see that in a second we
have lists you have lots of list
processing instead of functional
languages and you have tuples so this is
a positional thing let me see that okay
let's look at pattern matching for a
second so X equal five so we've got our
five there I'm going to say five equal x
that's a little weird
so what we're actually doing here this
is a pattern match and it's going to
evaluate the same it's happy to say yep
five is equal to X you know this is a
match and you can pin X down and say pin
X equal five and it's happy to say that
you know that's it
we just a pin X is equal to X plus one
it's going to bomb and say nope no it's
not thing's not equal to six
left hand size not equal to 6 we have
then pattern matches it can be against
more complex structures like tuples here
so we have ABC couple that matches
against apple banana cherry and we see
that we then bound b2 banana you know
and then Apple and C Apple to a and
cherry to C as well but that's what we
showed you in the shell pattern matching
will have a little bit bigger of an
example we have list here 1 2 3 C it
binds does a pattern match sort of as a
way of looking at but we're actually
assigning this thing so list is now
equal to 1 2 3 and we say case our list
and we're going to do pattern matching
here inside of this case statement so
and we're doing this in the shell here
you can have multi-line things you can
have complex bits inside of the shell
which is pretty awesome so we say case
list do we say 11 12 13 and this is not
going to match because 1 2 3 is not
going to match that right guess is going
to match oh not going to match because
this is a couple 1 2 3 rather than a
list 1 2 3 it's a different type right
here we have 1 X 3 and this is going to
match and it's going to bind the X that
came in it's going to bind the two to
the X in the middle and we can then use
that later on in the same case statement
to do our string interpolation and show
this we'll see that happen here so that
chasm binds to 2x digit separators this
is something that's coming and C sharp 7
I believe so it's good 1000 now so this
can say 100 underscore and say okay so
just pure candy I mean this is this is
about the dev joy side of the language I
mean there's just all these things that
just make life a little bit nicer you
know it's not important but it's it's
just awesome though thoughtful you know
so here we're going to look at a news
and streams so we're going to define an
anonymous function so a lot of times in
functions if you'll there's a convention
of if it returns a true or false you can
put a question mark at the end of it and
so that's a nice convention you see it
you know what to expect so we're going
to define this anonymous function that's
going to use the rim function so
remember it turns the remainder of two
numbers you know divided
so this is like modular and so so we say
rim
the first argument so the ampersand one
is going to take that first argument
that's passed in it's going to rim that
number comma two so we pass in a five
remainder of 5 comma 2 would be well 1
and so it's going to be an odd number
right so here we have a range we have 1
to 100,000 and we're going to pipe this
full word so any f-sharp people in the
room alright you'll recognize this so
we've got 1 to a 100,000 piping full
word in two so that each one of those
values are going to get pushed in is the
first argument to the thing on the right
so this functional pipelining a new map
and we're going to take whatever the
argument was we're going to multiply it
times 3 we're going to pipe that forward
into a new filter and we're going to
filter on our odd function that we
defined at the top and then we're going
to anew met we get our answer let's do
the same thing but this time we're going
to use stream map stream dot filter and
then we do a new him some so the
difference here we get the same result
the difference is is stream is lazy and
so on our first in our noon stage of
that we went through the whole
computation and we pass then that on to
the next series in the pipeline with
stream it's dragging you know one at a
time as you're coming through as it's a
pull based thing and these both work off
the same interface it's called
a protocol that they both they both
implement the enumerable protocol this
is like interfaces and c-sharp or the
protocol comes from closure where you
know this idea is directly borrowed I
mentioned strings earlier this is kind
of cool you know we can have straight-up
UTF awesomeness right here
so all the Norwegians with funny
characters in your names you can
appreciate this right so person equal so
let's look at maps
so we got our person named Brian beer
defaults I'm only beardy in the winter
not beardy in the summer and so we can
access it by key like this person name
you can access it by dot like this get
the same thing we can build a new map
based on an old map and just push in the
properties are the keys that we're going
to change we're going to override and so
we have then same thing Brian hunter
here okay let's look at strux yes yep
yeah I could do person and it's still
there it's just we have a new
everything's a copy there's you know
it's not mutating so good question here
this builds up on top of that idea but
gives us some extra goodies so we're
going to define this module called
person here we're going to put a def
struct in here when we say name and
we're going to give it a default of
empty string and we're going to say
beardy and it's going to default to
false and we then have this data
structure that we can start using so I
say a person I get my defaults I'm going
to say Brian is equal to a person named
Brian so we see person B R defaults
named Brian I say a person named Brian
bar defaults boom there's no such thing
as bar D so we got protected by using
the wrong key there there's no such
thing as bar D there's beardy and you
know so it blew and barked and kept us
from getting in this all sorts of
trouble that you've probably all
experienced with JSON already versatile
this is a really crazy thing so the
language you expect certain things out
languages here we have something you
would only expect to be able to do in C
so we have so we have the bit syntax and
we're going to run through this really
quickly we're going to grab okay bin
data and we're going to read this file
so if we look back on this image this is
a five pixel wide black red green blue
white and this is the data below so
we're going to read this file capture it
we captured bin data we captured the
binary data there to the bin data
variable we're going to set up a pattern
match where we're going to catch on the
Left using this DSL called
syntax we're going to catch on the left
the data if it matches against Ben data
here and so we'll see how that worked so
here's our data again our left two bytes
has to be be m and a bitmap so you can
just go through and just think about
data struck by Nerys out there and you
can just implement using this DSL and be
able to process like whatever your your
your protocol is that your you're trying
to implement your your format so that
was a match we're going to throw away 64
bits we're going to capture a 32 bit
little endian into a variable called
offset pixels throw away grab 5 height 1
size we're going to throw 16 bits away
we're going to make sure that the next
thing is a 24 here and then we're going
to throw the rest of it away now we're
going to say that offset 2 pixels this
told us where the actual pixel data
begins and we're going to remember that
and we're going to throw away that many
pixels and we're going to capture the
rest of it into a variable called
pixels we do that so we saw our values
that were here so we have this for
comprehension where we're going to
capture we're going to shuffles in 8
bits 8 bits 8 bits into blue green red
and here we go we've got our data so
that's one line one screen worth of code
inside of the shell and we've you know
parse bitmap which is kind of Awesome so
something borrowed a lot of things
borrowed one things borrowed is Erlang
VM our Lang VM grew up out of ericsson
doing awesome serious hardcore telecom
things we're focused on fault tolerance
so to have fault tolerance you have to
have concurrency if you don't process
dies you're fully down you have to have
distribution if you don't box catches on
fire you're fully down so those things
are important and you see the track
record of in fact your phone works and
that over half the world's mobile
traffic is going through Erlang which is
pretty incredible the data text voice
more recent story is whatsapp with with
their victories on the Erlang VM you
know so
just amazing amazing numbers here a
billion active users a month and so on
and another number that's important to
the business is 19 billion dollars they
were paid by Facebook there's 10
engineers building this mighty codebase
we look at what they're laying VM is in
context we have the runtime we have OTP
we have languages of Erlang elixir list
flavored Erlang there's a talk here this
week on list flavored Erlang by Robert
Verdi and so here's why people can't
just grab the Erlang VM like Erlang bits
and pull it into their language and it
comes down to this thing as an operating
system and it took a lot of time to
build it it's a serious operating system
it's not a general purpose operating
system on Linux or Windows it's a
special purpose operating system about
making a safe place for code to run 250
plus years our development went into it
you can see an example of it being an
operating system on Erlang Gon's in the
zurich demo and this boots up what would
take 300 seconds to boot up a Linux VM
on ec2 here they boot up into an
instance of bare metal Erlang running on
the Xen hypervisor it boots up and mill
milliseconds brings up Erlang VM runs a
web server processes things kicks out
your request and you have this result in
0.3 seconds pretty awesome so look at
the job of an operating system which are
linked VM is process management
interrupts memory management file system
so on and so on
and think about what our code does our
c-sharp our C our JavaScript as a job
and that job is to eat as much core as
it possibly can is trying to do oh it's
only worried about itself it's not
interested about the safety of the rest
of everything running on the machine and
so the operating system kind of has to
hate you it has to hate your code it
can't trust it and this is the place
where it's really different on the
Erlang B M is because the Erlang code
cannot do things to hurt the stability
the Erlang code itself has to play by
the rules that they're laying VM setup
for it are laying VM doesn't have to
support C in Java and Ruby and all these
languages it supports languages that
only
are going to do things that they're
laying VM allows them to so that Trust
is nice when you can cooperate you can
get a lot done when everyone's fighting
against each other you don't get a lot
done and so this is a big part of that
story so we got our Shaun of the Dead
reference cricket bat processes so
processes is the way we win here so
concurrency concurrency is not the same
thing as parallelism a lot of times
those words get used interchangeably but
concurrency is about the structure doing
lots of things at once and parallelism
is about the execution of lots of things
at once this comes in on a story at
Ericsson so when they built Erlang in
1986 they weren't targeting multi-core
machines in Stockholm
then they didn't have any tips this year
this is this wasn't a thing then and so
they built concurrency and they didn't
build it so they could go twice as fast
they built concurrency so they could
code without getting twisted up into
these horrible nests of callback e
weirdness and into thread weirdness and
they wanted to make the code simple to
read and to write because code that
simply read and write is less buggy and
that helps your fault-tolerant story so
they did this massive moonshot from 86
and then they turned on multi-core in
2006 and code they've been written a
decade before it did then run twice as
fast on two cores four times as fast on
four cores and like 2010 or 11 there was
a test where at linear scaling up to 40
cores on properly written Erlang code we
get that same thing in elixir because
it's the same VM all compiles down to
the same beam so let's look at elixir
and the Erlang VM and the actor model so
every actor gets some props so our
actors are processes so every process
gets these props one is memory so each
process is one kilobyte on a 32-bit
machine it's two kilobytes on a 64-bit
machine instead of this memory here we
have a heap and a stack and it's that
processes only no one else can reach in
and grab a reference to memory inside of
that process it's isolated
and it's also immutable right because
it's it's functional and so garbage
collector easiest job in the world be a
garbage collector on the erlang p.m. cuz
you know no one's only one person's
looking at the memory you can't change
it once it's set and so you each of
these processes they get their own
isolated dedicated garbage collector so
there's not going to be a big stop the
world GC that happens each one gets
garbage garbage collected independently
which is pretty amazing and that's done
for low latency and it's done for
deterministic scheduling our mailbox
this is the only way our process talks
to the world so last for York so we we
talked to the world through a metal
mailbox this is the only way a process
can reach out and so we send a message
out of our mailbox we address it to
another process it makes it innocent box
when they go into a perceived block
links and monitors is the thing that we
build up on to create some fault
tolerance goodies this is at this OS
level this Erlang VM level where we get
links and monitors links basically like
I'm going to link to josée over here and
if Jo's a dies I'm gonna die with them
okay Sonny back here there's a different
sort of thing like so so Sonny I'm gonna
monitor to Sonny back here so Sonny dies
well I don't really exactly want to die
you know but I'd like you to tell me
about it you know tell me if Sonny dies
I actually care about him but I dunno I
don't want to die and so so it's a
different level of commitment there and
so that's these two tools you have out
of the box so process scheduling on the
Erlang VM we have a CPU core we have a
single scheduler that lives on that CPU
core get three processes up and each one
of these processes is going to get 2,000
swipes at the core mm mm mm there's
nothing in the world they can do to eat
more core than mm swipes they can't
block and hold up the show everyone gets
even is pre-emptive scheduling here so
this is another way of visualizing it
they each get this much and they get
thrown back into the rotation same thing
happens if there's multi-core
if there's big multi-core yeah all
happening so we also have this the
supervision bit off the links and
monitors is talking about we have a
supervisor and a worker the worker
something happens the network cards down
the hard drive fail whatever we have
some weirdness the supervisor can then
restart the worker and this is important
because what do you do when you call
tech support about something the story
is rebooted right that's the first thing
to walk you through and it always works
and you're like God I worked again and
so this model is built in into Erlang it
works so well for tech support that they
included it as the part of the language
so process running the process running
in boom he falls into a receipt block
he's going to sit here forever and ever
and ever blocking waiting for a message
to appear in his mailbox no one's
talking to him so he's going to see here
well does that wreck the show have we
now blocked and wrecked the show well no
we haven't because the Erlang VM
schedules him out of the mix and then we
scheduled in across the other two
remaining cores back and forth and we
don't bring this guy back into the mix
until the postman the Erlang VM the
operating system until he knows that
that process actually has mail when it
does he's brought back into the fold
part of the rotation this includes
things like file i/o
so any sort of i/o that we have goes
through message passing like this so
even though I write file read earlier on
that bitmap file when I said file read I
was talking to another process and then
I waited for that process to send me a
message back you know I didn't have to
do this as a developer it's just part of
file and the read function on there it's
part of gen server and so at the point I
asked for that file immediately when I
asked for it that processes over there
doing the file reading and I'm removed
from the rotation until I have a message
in my inbox so now I'm blocking i/o that
you don't have to worry about you can
treat like sequential code it's really
done right here four cores four
schedulers you got processes and we have
this game of balancing compaction so
that happens and so busy scheduler busy
scheduler I'm not so busy I'm going to
take some work from this guy move it
over here so that this
scheduler can get sleepy and the whole
core can go to sleep and this will
happen so you get this compaction across
your cores and in a server closet you'll
have half your cores being able to go to
sleep on if they're running early which
is pretty amazing for power savings this
core memory locality things are building
up here he's getting hot hot
this one is us more stealing take it
make it even Steven balanced so at this
game where we we play and we get massive
concurrency pre-emptive multitasking
soft real-time low latency and the low
latency is valued more than raw
throughput which is an unusual
characteristic for a language scheduling
parallelization and fault tolerance an
ode because you pretty much left to your
own devices here I mean things you know
you're gonna be you know you're gonna
build build your own build your own
operating system every project or use
something out there that someone else's
had to do so on node we have cooperative
multitasking and on elixir we have
pre-emptive multitasking so cooperative
multitasking it sounds good right but
what it means is you have to cooperate
and if you don't you can wreck the
entire scheduling system on elixir you
cannot do that single threaded event
loop
single-thread event loop cooperative
multitasking it's like they read my mind
what we do when we work you know we get
into this trouble with callbacks and I
know that this is one that you've heard
a lot about and there are a thousand
blog posts out there saying there's no
such thing as callback hell that's a
myth and all this but a lot of people
are talking about it so it's it's some
people experience it but you there's
discipline you can follow all these
paths you can go down this route and you
can solve your callback hell problem and
have flat code by hoisting things around
and flattening things out and you know
on and on and on all these patterns if
you're a diligent person there's a funny
use of words and node but we'll talk
about that in a second but so no jest is
not aa mcli manage the number of workers
for you however it's your responsibility
to manage the worker pool for your
application needs so know it's easy that
doesn't sound easy distribution tends to
be very unbalanced due to operating
system scheduler vagrancy vagaries loads
have been observed where over 70% of all
connections ended up on just two
processes out of a total of eight well
that would suppose to be easy that
doesn't sound easy to me okay here let's
talk about elixir and simplified
distribution and I think I actually do
have time for this demo which is really
awesome and surprising
okay so here we have just a simple loop
called blabber and
I'm going to move over here and then use
I've got three consoles a terminal
window to set up and I'm going to start
up an ie X and I'm going to pass it s
named cat with a cookie of taco here I'm
going to start up a IX with the name of
dog with a cookie of taco and here I'm
going to do bird with a cookie of taco
so I've got these three named virtual
machines these three nodes brought up
here okay
and if I say node list I don't have any
friends yet so say node connect and I'm
the cat so I want to connect to the bird
and it says true so if I say node list
again I see this the bird he knows that
something's happened to and he's like oh
hi cat knows about me
so I say node not connect and I want to
bring the dog into the mix because the
dog always you know saves the cat right
it saves the saves the bird from the cat
so here I go back over here do my node
list Oh
so we all know about each other at this
point so we have a full mesh between
these nodes and that's all it took to do
this
this can happen across multiple boxes
across heterogeneous hardware so 64-bit
windows 32-bit Linux a raspberry pi on
ARM architecture and we can have code
this cluster formed and we can deploy
code across these so the decoder I'm
interested in deploying here is this
blabber server so we're going to spawn
this process start we're going to call
start which is going to spawn this
process based on this server loop here
this is a really short piece of code
here we're going to respond to receive
block we're going to wait for someone to
send us a stop message if we don't after
200 milliseconds we're going to say nice
we've got some uptime here and then
we're going to tail call loop into our
self passing plus one so that's our
logic so let me LS make sure that that
code is there I'll say you compile
blabber just a barber blabber just to
make sure that I've got a fresh good one
here okay and I'm going to say I'm going
to store off a pig equal blabber start
okay so I've got my process ID that was
returned from that and I'm here I'm
seeing nice zero years of bug free up
time on cat at Daedalus okay I'll go
over here that's like I'd kind of like
to do that too
so I say pit equal blabber start da I
don't know anything about that because
I'm not over here on bird or it wouldn't
exist there either but what I can do
here is I can say NL and I can say NL
blabber and so what happened then is I
just deployed my code to all my
connected nodes so over here on dog I
can now say pit blabber start and it
works and I can go back over here and I
can say I want to spawn this process on
another node let's say pit 2 is equal to
node dot spawn and I'm going to spawn
that on the bird node and I'm going to
spawn it bypassing the node name I pass
in the module name and I'm going to pass
in the function name to call and I'm
going to pass in the arguments which is
an empty list right and so now this
process is running over on bird we've
got the one running on here but we're
actually getting the IO piped to us it's
running over on this box if we kill this
thing we would no longer be getting this
message on the left saying six years of
bug free up time okay so that's pretty
cool I think so here let's fix some code
we've got a bug in here don't we
where's our bug here we're uh we don't
have enough gust oh it's our problem our
bug here on this line is we need more
gust oh we need an exclamation point
here okay so let's go over here we fixed
our bug we're going to ship this code
and so we're going to first recompile it
and so we get this our next tale call
into this our bug is hot code deployed
on our running server and I say NL to
deploy this code to my other servers
and notice what's happening there over
on our other cluster we are on another
node we have that picked up and it
deployed over here to this one as well
because in its output is being piped
back to us so this is pretty crazy
awesome is what this is and and it's a
sort of examples I can show about this
is a basic way of showing how you the
foundations of how the real stuff works
okay so we've got to now hurry because I
took the luxury of a sweet sweet demo
okay so let's talk just briefly about
OTP so this is where the safety and
fault-tolerance story really comes in
and it's built up on these basic things
that we all get by using they're laying
vm by using elixir we get applications
we get supervisors and we get gen
server's gen servers is where we do the
work and these all play with this nice
system and this is proven at Ericsson
over this decades on these systems that
have nine nines of uptime so we're
talking milliseconds a year and so you
know common sort of thing if you know
everything has to be carrier grade for
it to be Telecom which is five nines but
you actually beat that with Erlang
because of these amazing bits here so
application supervisor gin server this
is sort of looking at the tree of it so
an application spins up and brings up
all of the things that need to run in
the context of that application so
you'll start up you'll have super vision
where that super vision is then over
here watching you know our gen server
right and if that gen server hits some
weirdness and dies it'll restart if this
gen server down here causes some trouble
or any of its peers we've got a bunch of
gen servers being supervised by this
supervisor if any of those croak this
supervisor is going to restart them if
it happened so often we meet some
threshold the supervisor here could
actually be killed and if that happens
this supervisor is going to bring that
back up and so you have these whole
trees of these things depending on the
what you expect to happen in the code
and how nasty you see the problems being
so in elixir we code the happy path we
don't have a bunch of try catchy stuff
worrying about like oh what's going to
happen because you never can really
predict it
you can predict something
but you should maybe just coat it
differently but what's easier is to code
the happy path things go weird just let
it crash let the process crash and leave
that problem of handling the error to
supervision on this side different story
unhandled exception means your
application by extension node.js itself
is an undefined state blindly resuming
means anything could happen and this is
right off of node.js org and this
terrifies me the safe way to code for
massive concurrency is to code
sequentially the easiest code in the
world is code that goes top to bottom
that you can just read instead of
callbacks are not really easy to grok so
you actually code top to bottom in
elixir code you've got massive
concurrency your coding top to bottom
it's not your job to think about all of
the plumbing of how the concurrency
works so think about this you've got a
hundred thousand connected users they're
making all these callbacks you're
running on the single threaded event
loop on this single process and you
don't really have a supervision model so
one of those dies so you've created this
attractive nuisance here no node is this
attractive nuisance where people come in
and they can just break their ass you
know you can really get hurt on this
thing and we we have all sorts of tools
that we've been talking about so far in
elixir where you you get out of this you
know pit of failure and you end up in a
place where it's just actually easier to
build systems at work it's easier to do
your day-to-day coding one of those
things is being able to code with a
powerful repple the shell there so when
I'm building my elixir code I try it out
in IX I can do all my things I can see
at work and when it works I push that up
and put it into tests to protect me
against regressions so this is like TDD
the part where you actually change your
interface by the way you call it you're
getting that costly inside of the repple
in it and then you can then voice that
code out to protect protect you against
regressions so this idea of testing is
big because it's big in the Ruby
community it's made very easy here in
elixir made easy by having good docks
and then dock tests like we saw earlier
website called the node way
talks about you know this is protecting
you from trouble kind of website it's a
guidance website no jess has always been
easy to grasp but difficult to master
their common fit falls never been
well-documented it's up to you through
painful trial and error you know on and
on and on and it's like oh my goodness
you know this is the thing this is the
tool that's supposed to be easy this is
what was going to make us be able to
write code more simply and deploy more
simply and it's just not what happens
because we are required constant
diligence there and we shouldn't do this
to ourselves we shouldn't do that we
shouldn't allow tools and frameworks and
languages to put us in that spot where
we're constantly having to be on guard
because we're fallible we're human
so at this spot we have now traveled
through our hero's journey here where
you've now had this introduction to this
thing and it's kind of up to you to go
off and and pick it up and do awesome
things with it and I think you're going
to be stunned about what you can pull
off and how it's not just easy at the
beginning it continues to be easy it's
easy as it can be should be I guess and
you know so hats off really for josée
over here for this thing he's built it's
absolutely stunning and so at the end of
this I love this on the hero's journey
that they actually end with this line
it's returned with the elixir so
hopefully you all will go and return
with the elixir my to closing bits here
our elixir it's a you know pure
sustainable joy is I think what you get
on a lick sir and you get something
maybe a little bit different over here
you know it's popular it's crazy and
it's dangerous and and I'm going back to
this country here at the end of the week
and so that's the world I live in so so
thank you all for being here we have
this over here so please vote and tweet
and and go off and install elixir and
have fun with it and then also come
right back in here in a minute for our
next session with yan cui and i saw an
f-sharp in the real world and so FP
track will be in this room all week
other than the workshops which is the
hour after lunch and for those would be
in workshop I think it's room 10 but
it's workshops in its where you can just
hang out with all the speakers in FP
track
and have them walk you through things
and so we'll have josée we'll have Joe
Armstrong we'll have Robert Verdi will
have Mattias Brenda vendor who ran the
f-sharp machine-learning workshop with
Evelina and so awesome bunch in there I
hope you join us for that and other than
that actually I cannot believe it I have
a minute and a half for questions is
anyone yes
what would switch I think so I think it
has that sweet spot it I mean it
definitely has a sweet spot of standing
up a website quickly that can handle
lots and lots of things but then you
know it's like you've got to then have
someone actually do the work and
yep they would there I mean that would
be it's easy to handle a hundred
thousand users on the Erlang VM this is
a this is a sweet spot of the language
that fault tolerance concurrency
distribution that's what it was built
for so back in the 80s that was what it
was built for a hundred thousand phone
connections coming in and people expect
their phone they did expect it before
mobile phones with apps you expected
your phone to work and so you had fault
tolerance so I remember as a kid when a
squirrel would get into the transformer
on the power lines and go and in the
house all the power will go out we would
pick up her phone and we call the power
company and that just tells you about
that sort of fault tolerant story and
it's real there and it's real because of
these tools and so again that Erlang VM
is why that's happening like over half
of the world all of the traffic for
mobile is going through this so massive
concurrency easy to do I mean it's just
the sweet spot as a language a place
where I would use node 4 is my think
maybe what you're getting at place where
I would use node is here where I am
using node this is Adam I think
JavaScript is a great language for the
client you know it I mean JavaScript
obviously works well in a browser and
you know it's it's a very good thing to
have on the client it's ubiquitous it's
out there people know it you know the
problems with it and you don't have a
hundred thousand people that are getting
it hurt if my atom crashes and so that
that idea of atom and electron there
talks here this week on electron I
believe and so you it's a good thing to
have it there it's really nice the
tooling they built up but I wouldn't
want to use it on something where I had
to count on fault tolerance and I
wouldn't want to have my company
building up on it for business logic and
I know companies that have done that
they got lured in their business logic
everything they ported from c-sharp
because of problems that they saw there
they didn't like what the experience
there they moved over to node and now
they're trapped
you know they've they're they feel like
they're in deep they've started bringing
in micro services which is basically the
the plea for help
so like when node shops start talking
about microservices what they mean is
like we've screwed up we're going to
have this tiniest bit of code part so
and it's like maybe this will get us out
of this trouble we're in well you think
about what functions are in processes
with a message passing that's that's
micro-services that's how you want to
handle that problem and so any other
questions yes yeah well this is a really
interesting one so you'll never ever
hear on the Erlang VM anyone talking
about monads but you have something that
so what is I uh monad 4 so we we know in
Haskell if we write in Haskell that we
want to have all of our code be sane and
we want to build a reason about the
world right but we still have to we have
to have side effects right if your code
doesn't have if it can't write to the
monitor if it can't write to the hard
drive it can't write to the network card
you're not actually going to get
anything done so you wrap that then
inside of the i/o monad well on elixir
in Erlang the equivalent of that would
be port drivers so all of my elixir code
my Erlang code it can only talk to other
processes through message passing right
can't reach out to the operating system
can't poke through do anything it's all
in that safe safe world so the way that
the the ugly scary world is hooked in is
through port drivers those are written
in C and they meet a certain interface
that makes them look to the Erlang VM as
if they are Erlang or elixir it you know
they look they look native on that side
but you got the scary scary world there
and the only thing that then can touch
the outside world is a port driver which
is a process which can be supervised and
so and you don't go off riding port
drivers all the time because you know
there's the file system there's a
network card they're these basic number
of things that you want to talk to on
the outside world and the way you do
that is through port drivers but I love
that question I forgot to actually
mention it earlier so thank you yes
so I'm always surprised it it you know
people talk well our lengths not a great
language for doing machine learning that
sort of thing well it turns out is
actually is pretty good at machine
learning and here's an example of so you
see the F sharp digit recognizer
project so the thing it's not good at so
I'll say that you can actually do this
and I explored this path of using it for
this thing it's not good at is it
doesn't have a static type system so
there are going to be errors that you
don't catch at compile time this is a
place where F sharp absolutely just
beats the hell out of us over on a lick
sir because static type system you catch
all these problems it depends on the
kind of code you're deploying and why
you're deploying it so if you're going
to a mobile phone for example where you
have to go through the Apple Store for a
week review and all this and you can't
change your code and and you can't get
users to install the new one you want to
catch every problem you can at compile
time so that's why I really am excited
you know like Sam read which I have my
Sam are insured under here you know you
have this F sharp support and there's
also a talk on F sharp and mobile coming
up a little bit later today but that's a
place where I would use F sharp for sure
over you know you don't even have the
option of using a lick sir on a mobile
phone but I would use it for those
places now on the server it's actually a
lot easier you think about this we did
this hot code deployment it's easier to
deploy that new elixir code to a server
than it would be if you had a static
type system with dll's and all that you
know I mean that was just crazy easy we
changed the code deployed across this
cluster and everything worked and so it
comes down to what your what your
deployment story is so I think in the
short run like if an app has to work
really really well immediately and it's
going to be really hard to update you
know that's a static type system problem
if it's something you know this other
side you have to have a system that runs
and runs and runs for years with no
downtime the static type system protects
you in that first hour you get your
maximum then it's kind of like term life
insurance that sort of thing you know
there's different thresholds when the
most valuable static type systems are
helping you the most right when you
deploy and that first a little bit is
live
something like elixir Erlang they're
helping you if you need that thing to be
running for years with no downtime okay
and I think I am now out of time so Yan
will be in here so don't get too far
away because John will talk about F
sharp in the real world and he is
awesome he's an amazing presenter so and
thank you all for being here this is
awesome